please welcome Diane Greene senior vice
president Google Cloud
okay welcome everybody thanks so much
so many familiar faces on behalf of our
entire Google cloud executive team we
want to welcome you here our customers
our partners and everybody else we're
pretty excited to give you this
September 29th sort of snapshot of where
we are forty weeks that's we're counting
by the week so much is happening that's
when we brought this whole team together
as one we're really functioning as a
team and I probably I'm sure I've talked
to over 200 customers and partners and
I've learned a lot from their customers
and our partners about the unique value
that Google's bringing and I want to
really talk about that to you today it's
been a wonderful discovery and I also
want to talk about the fact that when I
came in we were sort of Google for work
we were GCP we were Google Apps we were
the enterprise mobile devices and so
forth and and we'd go right you know
talk to the customers and I'd be there
with our top technology people and we
kind of blow our customers away and we
get to the end of the conversation and
I'd say so
any other questions and they go yeah you
know it's Google really serious about
the enterprise and it was you know kind
of driving us crazy and because we're
very serious about the enterprise that's
why we were all there and and and so we
said we maybe we better call ourselves
Google Enterprise so we started doing
that internally we started doing it
externally just to put a point on we are
serious about the enterprise and then a
couple months ago all of a sudden the
questions started dissipating people
seemed to be getting it we you know yep
they're kind of putting their money
where their mouth is they're serious
about the enterprise they're executing
they're delivering these things and
we're like enterprise
that was so Jun where we're the full
power of Google in the cloud we're
Google cloud and that's what our entire
organization is it's a uniquely Google
broad set of technologies solutions
products you know from all built for the
cloud from the Android and secure
Chromebook enterprise mobility devices
desktop devices to all of Google cloud
platform from the data centers up
through our data analytics the API is
the machine learning the smart data that
we make available to our developers the
Maps API is for the enterprise and our
much-loved amazing built for the cloud
completely integrated collaboration and
productivity suite of tools the you know
known as Google Apps changing the name
today all of this is Google Cloud and
and I have to say when we said this to
everybody at Google
there was just no questions everybody
kind of cheered let out a sigh of relief
everybody feels you know that work
Google cloud and this is you know the
cloud you know I came to to work on
Google cloud I knew it was just a
gigantic thing but you know it's the
biggest IT transformation ever what I
didn't appreciate was the pace I've
never seen anything like it
the pace is just relentless and it's
getting faster every day and and the
totally amazing thing given this pace is
where we are we're at the beginning so
Deutsche Bank took the top three public
cloud vendors AWS Google and Azure and
added up their estimated revenues and
then said well the IT industry is
something more than a trillion dollars
and it gets 5% where of the total
available market is where we are today
so we're moving fast we've got well over
10,000
engineers working on all this since
January 339 product releases including
things like new data centers new data
analytics functionality search
functionality for the apps and so forth
these next numbers are our growth in
revenue so storage I recently heard that
a health company there's a new health
company startup that's looking at two
petabytes per patient that they want to
keep unbelievable numbers of satellite
images coming down you name it storage
revenue 10x compute for X and we really
enjoyed this unprecedented historical
bumping compute we recently had where we
scaled up you know this phenomena of all
these zombies walking around into
fountains and so forth pokey Pokemon go
you know in kind of a matter you'll hear
later from them about that and then a
whopping 25 X growth in in managed
containers this is how people are
building apps developers are building
applications it's fast
it's simple you can concentrate on the
user facing functionality and let Google
take care of everything else
very exciting you'll hear more about
that too and then finally you know we've
always done really well with consumers
really well with small medium-sized
businesses and we really wanted to bring
I mean Google is one of the bigger
enterprises in the world and we're you
you know a hundred percent on our suite
of productivity and collaboration tools
Google Apps and and we said let's bring
this this really show companies all over
the world you know big companies how
this can transform their business and
really help them move faster and more
collaboratively more transparently so we
push for big customers which we defined
as more than 5,000 seats and we're
seeing 3 X growth it's
very exciting to us and that includes
like over 300,000 seats
several over a hundred thousand seats a
lot of big customers very happy said the
cloud you know how did it start well
initially it was a convenient way if you
were a startup you didn't have to buy
equipment servers storage if you were a
department that couldn't get resources
from your IT group you'd kind of use the
cloud and and and people were trying to
figure out if they were really saving
money
the smaller you board the more money you
would save and and and then you know
something happened where we started
getting all these breaches a medical
record per patient cost several hundred
dollars any where there's a breach we
all see all these breaches and and and
and it started dawning on people that
you really need scale to do security so
and so that's in the clouds so so really
in boardrooms people started saying
shouldn't you be looking at saving some
costs and the security of the cloud I
mean I can't tell you how many contacts
I get from people interested in hiring a
board member that has cloud expertise
it's become mission-critical to
companies to understand that and and
everybody's looking at moving I you
sometimes wish the pace would slow down
and so that's good that's fine but the
really interesting thing going on is the
digital transformation what's happening
with people becoming digital businesses
and and I'll give you an example if you
think about something like maps we all
used to go to the triple-a and get our
paper map before we went off in our car
on a trip and it got digitized it went
into the cloud and what that did was
really provide a platform for all kinds
of new business models all kinds of new
services for instance Waze figured out
they could take real time
perfect information and overlay it on
the maps what a phenomenal value to
customers whole new business whole new
set of value you know becoming digital
lets people move fast and they lets them
get real-time data and make real-time
decisions it's completely
transformational and every day new
technologies are coming out that let you
do it better and better and do it more
powerfully what that all says is if
you're going to move to the cloud who
your partner is really matters okay you
want someone that really is bold that's
thinking long-term that's built for
innovation that's going to keep you on
that innovation curve so that you can
compete and have the latest empowering
technology right away easily and simply
and I love this photo and I went to give
this talk it was my first slide I said I
want this slide in my talk because I
like the ocean and and this is us faster
this is a submarine cable laying ship
and what it's doing there in that
picture is we laid a cable from 9,000
kilometers from the u.s. to Japan
repeaters every sixty kilometers to
energize re-energize the light sixty
terabit per second that's I think 10
million or a hundred million I always
keep getting these orders a magnet n
million times faster more capacity than
a cable modem anyhow the point is this
is a big investment Google has the best
network in the world
I mean it's estimated we run 30% of the
world's Internet it's been publicly
estimated that we run 30% of the world's
Internet
I mean you we could we reach everywhere
in the world difficult to reach places
like Saudi Arabia of Africa we have to
for our 7 billion plus apps and actually
I'll digress once more we recently
figured
because of our customers that actually
Google has eight billion plus active
user apps because Google Cloud and its
users are clearly over a billion active
users but so anyhow so the point is you
want someone that's innovating that's
thinking long term and moving forward
this is a very exciting thing I like
that Google knows this I didn't fully
assimilate it till we were talking to a
customer of ours a big SAS vendor and
they kept asking questions well you know
what happens if the network had OHS down
and well how does the identity work in
all the different places in your system
and then finally this CIO CTO looked at
us in and he said you know what Google
actually has the most Enterprise
appropriate approach of any cloud and I
like and we you know what that is is
when we build something we think of it
as a system not as a bunch of components
that you the user have to kind of
assemble and hope it all kind of has the
same availability but if you're doing
data analytics and the network goes down
you can't get at your data analytics you
can't run it and and so anything that
would keep you from offering your
service is considered the system at
Google that's how we think that's how we
built Google from the beginning we had
to and so what that means is also Google
gets the cloud Google was started in the
cloud Google was built for the cloud and
so we can even give you a slider so you
can say if I don't want a high SLA if I
don't want high availability or
performance it costs Google less so your
price is less if you want you know the
five nines and the lowest latency it
costs you more but we can slide that and
because we took the system approach we
can do that I think it's a really big
deal
we're also doing you know Google does
have the best security you know we have
the over 600 people we do keep our
customers secure however our customers
need to convince their customers and
they need to convince the regulator's
that they are secure so what that means
is we are working with our customers to
knock off all the compliance badges that
they need to work with the regulators
together with our customers all over the
world and help them prove to the people
they need to prove it - that they are
secure a huge effort here when we
embrace very heartily and then machine
learning something Google invested in
pretty much from the beginning you know
today at Google we have a phenomenal
community of machine learning and AI
researchers we have Google brain we have
the alphabet companies deep mine fairly
now calico we have Google Cloud ml all
those research scientists a huge
assemblage of the world's best working
together as a community to move the
state-of-the-art forward and what we're
so excited about with Google cloud is we
can democratize it we can bring it to
everybody
Google brain open source tensorflow so
that everybody could do it and now we're
increasingly building the tools to make
it easy for any of our customers to take
their own proprietary data and train it
we also bring our smart data if you will
our train data the data you know and let
you query it through api's you can read
read text you can recognize you know
address you can you do speech you can do
speech recognition and so forth through
the api's direct to developers and of
course all of googles products as you'll
hear from pravakar and in our suite of
productivity apps are infused with
machine intelligence
and speaking of machine learning you
know so so in addition we're gonna have
you know a nice cross-section of our
customers today to tell you how they're
using it
Airbus using image image recognition to
detect clouds Home Depot who is also
using our recently acquired company
Apogee hasn't quite closed yet to do the
API management they're using Google
cloud and the API management to make it
easy for them to talk to their customers
and partners and then tell us
international the Canadian well
international telco 20,000 people all
over the world using Google Apps in
Chrome and then in a different category
we have snap and formerly snapchat and
they I think I get more excited than my
18 year old daughter now when they do a
new release because we're provisioning
for it and and then we'll have Pokemon
go talking about their recent debut and
and then finally Evernote which which
was on Prem has been on prem they
recently decided to move to the cloud we
were pretty excited to win the bake-off
they'll be telling you their CEO will be
here telling you why and and we also are
pretty excited about
we deeply embrace partnering at Google
and and Evernote is one we're partnering
deeply around Google Apps with for the
benefit of our mutual customers we've
also got pur partners here we have
pivotal making it easier for our
developers to quickly build apps
actually we have many many partners here
in the audience PwC and Accenture the
CTO of Accenture is here to announce our
partnership with them and talk about
what he's seeing
stepping back what's going on here you
know Google Google's been having huge
impact on the world right from the guy
go but we kind of think with with the
late 2013 release of Google compute
engine we kind of moved into the
exponent it's great to be in the
exponent it's leverage and the reason we
have that leverage now is it's not just
us it's why we're the eighth billion
plus active user sort of app at Google
with our customers with our partners we
are having an exponential impact all
over the world we think bringing our
technology getting our customers on our
technology curve it's actually going to
spur economies all over the world the
small start-up in Africa has the best of
Google's machine learning they can they
can do image recognition they can do
language translation they can use
everything we have and so they can
concentrate on their great ideas and
getting it into the market very quickly
this is unprecedented these kinds of
capabilities for everybody in the world
and that's what gives us this
exponential impact which we're all very
excited about and and so today you're
going to hear from the rest of our
Google cloud team our executives about
with announcements about some new
products that we have in all kinds of
areas and then also our customers our
partners and and so I'm going to wrap up
and I just want to kind of summarize
three big things of what I've been
talking about today one is just just the
excellence of our engineering and how
important this systems approach is I
also want to you know really emphasize
when you sign up to the cloud it's a
it's a bet it's a long-term bet in fact
I have had two customers now
that went to evaluate Google cloud and
one of them in particular said that they
were kind of looking for a reason not to
look at Google cloud who wants to learn
something new and they couldn't find it
and then they caucused among themselves
and the other and they said you know
what we decided we decided in five years
Google will have one
a little endless I can barely say it it
makes me so happy
okay so so and it's because of the
technology curve we're going to get
people on and when you compare our
products to our competitors products
apples to apples they're just plain
better and and and and we're closing the
gap incredibly fast and then finally we
are you know Google's about substance
it's a technology company we want to
partner with our customers we want to
make them successful we're merging two
sets of Technology our customers and
ours and that requires partnering and
technical interaction and that's what
we're doing and Tuareg who leads our
customer facing I'll tell you more about
that